[Music]
[Applause]
right now we've got my guy Tom Curran
from NBC Sports Boston two very
important topics to get to with Tom Tom
always great to see you great to talk
with you let's start with the awards
because you are one of the I don't know
is it 50 or whatever AP voters 50 AP
voters when are the are the awards due
like when do you have to get your vote
in a the All Pro is due Monday at five
and the awards are due Wednesday at five
different format for the Awards this
year two Ross because we're voting kind
of in a in a one through five points
value as opposed to just saying This Is
My Player of the Year this is my MVP now
it's staggered I can vote for one two 3
four five for MVP so there'll be a point
point system involved which is an
interesting way to do it and I think
it's a great way to do it I think it's a
much better way to do it don't you
because I mean there might be a guy that
gets a bunch of second place votes or
whatever and other guys get some first
place votes but then other people don't
think they're as good for a certain
award that's that's a more reasonable
mathematical way to go about it yeah and
I remember you know we'll have the
conversation forever about whether the
quarterback should always be the MVP I
do tend to always air on the side of the
quarterback because he handles the ball
on every single play he makes a decision
he holds the fortunes of the teams in
his hand he gets teams in and out of
plays he has to be the franchise hood
ornament so you have to be Beyond
exceptional to unseat a quarterback but
then you also you know I guess the
obvious is Christian mcaffrey versus
Lamar Jackson or even throw in CD lamb
for the hell of it those three guys look
to me were miles Garrett you got four
guys who could all be you can make a
case for each one in one way or another
so at least this way you get to throw it
at each guy somehow right so if they ask
you your opinion would you want to wait
till after the playoffs are over for
these
Awards you know what it's really an
opportunity missed by the NFL to not
have a playoff type MVP like you know
how they do an all tournament team in
the
NCAA I my point Tom is like let's say
you're torn on Coach of the Year between
Kevin stefansky and whoever wins the
Texans Colts game tomorrow night right
yep well like if the Browns go to the
Super Bowl the AFC Championship Game it
would be stupid if it was like Sten was
the coach of the year you know mean like
I just feel like right the playoffs
matter and for defensive player of the
year and for it's I think it's weird and
I understand why the vote is before the
playoffs but what we remember the most
about a season is what happens in the
playoffs so to vote for the awards
before the most important games happen
the game that we remember it kind of
skews things when we then think wait a
minute that guy didn't win MVP or that
guy wasn't Defensive Player of the Year
Michael Parson had seven sacks in those
two playoff games you know you're 100
perc right and it's interesting because
those are the games like you'll look at
for instance I've made the case that at
least Julian utman should be spoken
about in a Hall of Fame conversation
people go he's never he was never a pro
bowler he's never an all pro and say
you're right you're exactly right and
those are the standards by which Hall of
Fame voting is done to allow L extent
you don't even get there if you don't
have those things but he's the second
all-time leading receiver in the
playoffs and the number of memorable
plays that he's made in Super Bowls and
AFC Championship Games should make him a
fabric of the history of the NFL again
I'm not making a Hall of Fame case for
Julian
Edelman but at least a consideration
because those are the those are the more
important games than the you know a
December game between you know the
Titans and the Panthers I mean whatever
somebody goes off in that game big deal
deal you go off in February that's a big
deal so then my other question would be
like let's say for example Defensive
Player of the Year okay yes I don't
think Miles Garrett's gonna play on
Sunday for the Browns against the
Bengals I do think Micah Parsons plays
against the commanders so how will you
factor it in if Michael Parson say three
sacks against the commanders but Garrett
didn't play I mean is that a knock on
Garrett does it only help Parsons like
how do you how do you deviate between
those two yeah that's funny because like
would I do that with the week 10
matchups and compare the teams that they
were going against in that one and and
go back and compare week to week who do
they go against who they play or do I
look at the the body of work in games
that mattered and say okay you have the
best player on a defense that has
carried a team to the playoffs and is
already there and I think that I would
again I'm going to spend more time on it
but I would lean towards miles Garrett
in that sense now you're a voter too
right no I'm not Oh I thought you were
no if I was a voter I wouldn't have
brought you in I would just said all the
stuff myself good point by you good
point by you no what would you what
would you do with your
um what would you do with your coach of
the year vote and should I think it's I
think it's Kevin stansky should
quarterbacks get the benefit of the
doubt that we tend to give them as MVPs
I feel really strong that that you give
25% weight to playing that position yeah
I think it's that valuable I mean and
honestly you know even like when you
talk to like guys about betting in
sports books other players don't move
the line the betting line nearly as much
as quarterbacks which if we're talking
value if we're talking how many points
they make a difference in the outcome of
games as great as mcaffrey is you know
it's just very difficult when you
compare it to a quarter back I have a
question for you what do they tell you
guys about comeback player of the year
because that is such a weird award and
it's like well I don't know I guess
Brock pie came back from elbow surgery
and Joe flacko came back from retirement
or the couch and you know Demar Hamlin
came back from obviously that horrific
uh tragic in almost tragic incident like
I don't know how you're comparing these
guys because it's like three different
animals yeah it's completely you know
subjective and
with Demar Hamlin has his have his
contributions to the bills been the same
that Baker Mayfields or Joe flacos were
certainly not was his
situation miles and miles and galaxies
more dire than theirs and the point to
which he came back he traveled a further
road yeah he definitely did so are we
talking about the impact made and the
place that you started at as that's a
breathtaking comeback or production on
the field so there's no guidance given
it's a
subjective measure and I think that that
is just a great conversation Point too
is to what would you use as a fan
because there's no way to measure what
would you use as a fan to measure um The
Comeback what would you say uh well I
think you got to perform on the field I
think it's not just coming back from
something I think you have to then take
it on I mean awards are supposed to be
for accomplishments on the field not
just getting back I feel like Hamlin's
like in a different category it's you
know what I mean it's uh it makes it
tough we're talking with my buddy Tom
Curran NBC Sports Boston and he's got a
perfect backdrop which lets you know
that he's the host of the Patriots Talk
podcast which is awesome let's get into
that by the way Tom I you probably
here's my first
question on a daily basis how many
people ask you what's going to happen
with belich when you walk around when
you're anywhere in your life you go to
the mall do people still go to malls
whatever wherever you go when you're
around family how many times a day do
you think someone asks you what's going
to happen with bich I would say the
percentage of people asking
me in a setting in which the
gym Dunkin
Donuts I would say it's really close to
uh it's a percentage call it 70% what's
gonna happen what's gonna happen with
Bill so what so so typically do you go
and get the donuts and coffee before you
work out or after you work out that's
going to be uh it's just going to be a
coffee first off we're not going to go
with the donuts we're going to get the
coffee early and we're going to work out
later but in the course of the
conversation I I say what I'll tell you
what I say they made a
decision can Bill wriggle off the hook
can Bill somehow be persuasive enough in
a meeting at the end of the
season for the crafts to change their
minds and say you know what let's run it
back look the the circumstances don't
lend themselves right now to us moving
on because Ross that's that's the Crux
of it as I reported you know in mid
December at that juncture after they had
come out of Germany not because of the
game in Germany and the loss to the
Indianapolis Colts but at that
point conversations I had indicated
strongly that the
Patriots were going to part ways with
Bill at the end of the season and a
decision had been made has he done
enough in the five weeks since to change
it or as ownership scrutinizes the
situation do they say are we setting
ourselves up to be a better team next
year is this what's good for the
football team and that's a question that
I think they certainly have to answer
before they make the ultimate decision
on Bill and actually follow through with
it so you can make a decision you and I
can both decide to you know jump off
cliff but if we both get to that Cliff I
go Russ it's pretty high it's kind of
windy do you want to come back tomorrow
when it's less
windy do you do you think he definitely
wants to be
back every indication I've gotten from
folks uh reporting on it have has
indicated that does okay CU I didn't
know if maybe he was ready to go to the
Chargers or go somewhere else and try to
try to win and and and break this record
sooner yeah but the interesting thing
and I spoke to somebody on the staff uh
yesterday they said one of the most
remarkable things about this has been
Bill's consistency he has shown not one
inkling of drama he hasn't blinked a bit
he hasn't mentioned it the staff is
completely in the dark and given the
craft family has not yet spoken with
Bill bellich our buddy Mike re reporting
that Monday is when the conversation
will take place Bill's in the dark so as
of this time there's no conversation
held which to
me it seems really hard Russ doesn't it
to sit down on Monday and start trying
to figure out how the best way to move
forward is if you're going to keep
bill you agree with me absolutely if
they were going to keep him they would
already be talking about offseason plan
and stuff like that let me ask you this
Tom what would be his argument like
pretend I'm Robert Craft and you're bill
bich and we sit down and I say Bill I
think I think we're going to move on
like try to try to sell me on on you're
Bill Bell Che try to sell me on why I
should keep you perfect it look it's
been one season okay we were eight and
nine I kind of thought we were heading
in the right direction with Matt last
year you didn't M Jones was playing well
at the end of the year Well you wanted
to switch it off offensive coordinator
and I love Bill O'Brien so I said all
right let's make that switch in the end
Mack
regressed we had injuries we had Cole
strange out we had Michael wenu out we
had uh a right tackles who I signed in
free agency neither of them were able to
get on the field period so our offensive
line was in disrepair so we weren't able
to protect Mack and as a result his
decision- making really ended up being
pretty bad so we were victimized by
injuries but if you look Robert you look
at our defensive side of the ball we
lost Matt judon and Christian alz our
two best defenders and we are one of the
best teams in the league defensively and
if it wasn't for the turnovers and if it
wasn't for the mistakes we would be fine
now we got a quarterback heavy draft we
got a top five pick we got $68 Million
worth of cap space don't you want
somebody who's experienced at the point
of the spear here making these decisions
I can take care of this it's there's
circumstances that injected themselves
into this year that made it this way so
don't talk to me about the Brady
decision don't talk to me about the
money that we spent in free agency two
years ago don't talk to me about all the
draft picks we've missed Robert you know
and I know that I'm the greatest coach
of all time and I stand on that but Bill
it's not a one-year thing it's been
three out of the last four years and
you're the guy in charge of everything
so why would your backup quarterback be
a guy that you were willing to cut and
put on the practice squad in Bailey's
zappy you could have given yourself a
better option there in case M Jones
altered yeah you got me on that
one I mean Joe I mean look look at Joe
flacko he's standing out there he's
minding his own business we certainly
could have brought him in in August and
not have to have suffered through Mac
you know what's interesting Tom by the
way and and I don't know how often you
go on stations in other cities the thing
that's most interesting to me do you
know that these other C they don't want
them yeah you like in other words I've
been on in DC and I said I think there's
a decent chance you guys get bich
because I think Josh Harris will you
know he's a hedge fund guy it's buying
low buying bich low and it gives
credibility and he's like we don't want
him I'm like what do you mean they they
estimated 10% of Washington football
fans would want bellich then I'm on in
Charlotte and I thought I can see teer
doing that teer needs some credibility
terer needs a guy like this they don't
want him down there either and maybe
it's just short attention span and maybe
if they hired him Tom they would feel
differently but I was blown away how
many of these fan bases don't seem to
want like it it would not be a slam dunk
home run people excited about it higher
because of what happened this year I've
said the same thing you know beginning
when the speculation was was hot or
began to warm up I said I don't know if
people are going to be lining up for
Bill bich and people in our Market said
you're crazy there's definitely going to
be people and I've actually moved off of
that stance given after my report how
many people said teams will line up but
I think fans who say I don't think I
want that guy are looking at the draft
history are looking at the offense and
saying it's an offensive league and
they're scoring 10 points a game and the
reason they're scoring 10 points a game
isn't because of Bill O'Brien and it's
not totally because of M Jones it's
because of the totality of the decisions
made on the offensive side of the ball
jacobe Meers is going off on another 70
Catch season for 700 yards and the
Patriots said no we don't want him give
us Juju the guy right in front of you
and you don't want him Tom Brady's right
in front of you and you're trying to
move him out the door and you finally
get him out and he goes and wins a Super
Bowl so to me Ross you were here when
the Patriots were an outstanding team
Bill's involvement with offense and his
ability his ability to cultivate offense
has always
been propped up helped aided by very
able assistant coaches whether it be
your line coach here Dante scari or the
offensive coordinator
and I think that's where the the rubber
meets the road for Bill's next spot so
there's a strong possibility Tom this is
his last game there and last press
conference will you miss him in his
press conferences or if you're being
honest will you be glad he's gone oh no
I I'll I'll definitely miss him Ross
definitely I mean it's if if it comes to
pass it's 24 years a covering the guy I
was here when he was here in 2000 we had
a lot of good times in press conferences
a lot of laughs even conversations on
the phone and in person away from the
stadium so it's been a good relationship
it's just that's where
the you know being AC cross purposes
exists with being a media person who
does analysis as well as information
gathering you have to analyze the
direction of the team and opinion eyesee
on well why are they the way they are so
that ex is going to end up fracturing a
relationship if I'm keep saying bill has
run this team kind of into a ditch and
it's smoking and you have to make a
decision to move on um that's the job to
look at it objectively but certainly the
what the you know what he has meant to
this region the success I've had in this
business and the number of times I've
been on Dan Patrick is thanks in large
part to the fact I covered a team that
he was at the front of and helped to
make as good as it was so it's been
helpful for me obviously it's a really
really good point Tom always great to
talk with you man thanks for coming on
the show all right buddy have a great
weekend thank you absolutely there he is
Tom Curran NBC Sports Boston